we're going to talk about influencers
promoting crypto john can you tell us
what's going on here yeah so recently
kim kardashian posted a instagram story
promoting ethereum max etherio max is
the cryptocurrency and look this has
kind of been up in the air ever since
the ico started happening back in i
think 2017 um and look it
she isn't getting in trouble i want to
be clear about that she is doing
everything kind of right and by the book
but she clearly say that is an ad and
look ethereum max is they're paying
influencers which is seems like to be
like the new game to pay influencers uh
to be able to promote their
cryptocurrency their product anything
really um but the fac the financial
conduct authority warned on monday that
consumer risk being lured into the
crypto bubble
with delusion of quick riches by high
profile
influencers such as kim kardashian right
so she has over 251 million instagram
followers and in 2019 a report came out
um when she did what a court filing yeah
that she gets paid 300 to 500k for a
single instagram post i personally think
it's way more than that you guys think
she only gets 300 500k i think she makes
way now hold on so this is a single
instagram post or an instagram story
post i don't know what's worth more it's
probably a post right it's permanent
post for sure was this was in this that
she posted was a it was a story yeah so
maybe she got three to 500k i don't know
if i'm kim kardashian i'm not chilling
coins online for 300 000 right like
that's a lot of money for sure don't get
me wrong but she's rich she's got a lot
of money she'll need 300 000 now she's
got freaking regular regulators uh
coming down her back saying you did the
wrong thing i think ethereum max they've
done this with a couple other people now
i don't know much about their business
or anything like that uh i know they
promoted it with floyd mayweather it was
the it was on his shorts during the
fight with the with logan paul uh you
could buy tickets to the fight with with
ethereum max they've promoted it with a
few other people kim kardashian now also
the thing i think is interesting is
this token uh it's super volatile
obviously right and kim kardashian was
okay with promoting it to people for
cash so the token i don't know what day
it was but it's gone up 70 in value in a
single day and it's gone down 98 value
in a single day so imagine promoting
something and it was very clear you know
she said the whole this is not financial
advice but then she clearly stated uh
that they're burning coins and 50 of the
supply is getting reduced today so go
check it out to me that means buy right
so you're essentially leading your
followers to uh to a service that you
don't know anything about probably i
doubt she owns any of the coins herself
uh and it's clearly volatile and people
have lost money on it so i thought it
was interesting that for someone who has
so much money yeah i would assume they
had to pay way over the three four five
hundred thousand dollar mark to get this
done for sure but do you think
like why do you think she's who do you
think advised her to do this
that's the thing i i don't know right
like do you think they just came with
such a big bag and they were like look
we're gonna pay you five million dollars
to promote this and she was like all
right that's a no-brainer or do you
think they they i don't know like i
wouldn't again i wouldn't uh assume that
she would do this for anything less than
than what she's getting for the other
stuff so i give her credit she said not
financial advice at the start and has
the tiny little bit hashtag ad at the
bottom where is the ad it's yeah she hit
it oh i see it yeah yeah so i think
that's another important thing to point
out she covered her bases instagram was
like kim kardashian did nothing wrong
she put the ads she made it clear to her
followers that this was not financial
advice etc and i don't even think the
regulators are looking into her for
doing anything wrong i think the
regulators were like she said it wasn't
financial advice it is what it is but
they're more concerned about the
industry as a whole with uh the ability
for someone to just create a token right
or a coin on one of these exchanges and
then go start paying celebrities promote
it so essentially anyone with a bunch of
cash can go out and promote their token
increase the value they own a bunch of
the coins themselves and they increase
their net worth and all this stuff so i
think from an industry standpoint it's
much more concerning but i don't
necessarily know if she did anything
wrong
at least at least uh you know legally
maybe morally her followers are like
you don't feel good about it
would you promote something like this
never i was just thinking for 500k
if i was rich and famous i would not be
promoting anything yeah like you
couldn't pay me enough money to get in
trouble with the regulators like that's
ridiculous
but look she covered all her bases and
uh i don't know if you guys remember uh
floyd mayweather and dj khaled got in
trouble because they promoted icos that
they were a part of they got paid for it
and then they didn't disclose that
information any other following um was
it floyd got fined 615k and dj khaled
got fined around 150k kind of based on
what they got paid from them and all
that so it's important when you do this
stuff to make it very very clear that
you are being paid and it's an
advertisement um for those companies
wait somebody had a good point they said
did she get paid in ethereum max
obviously not yeah you think she got no
no i doubt
it cuz the thing uh the thing about
these it's super volatile right so she's
not gonna accept something that knows it
can go way down in value the the reason
why and this is my uh thing with a lot
of these announcements that come out
whether it's all the crypto exchanges
that sign professional athletes do deals
with teams ethereum acts with kim or
whatever it is a lot of these uh
athletes will take them in stable
generally stable cryptocurrencies
whether it's uh bitcoin ethereum or
whatever
and then some of them will do just a
small amount so basically they'll say
they got paid part of the deal in crypto
and it makes it go viral with marketing
everyone loves it and it promotes it
much more but at the end of the day
you're not going to do it with ethereum
max because you have no idea where this
is going to end up she could sell it
that day and it could crash and she
could lose a bunch of the money right so
i just looked it up she's worth 1.2
billion dollars so even if she got paid
a million dollars for this right like
granted a lot of money but relative to
her it's not anything compared to kind
of how much she has from a net worth
basis so it's like
you have to weigh it out from you're
pissing off 235 million fans versus a
million dollars
it can it can tarnish your brand for
sure but uh i think floyd said the quote
of like money talks he's just like look
if they pay you white will do it if they
pay you enough like they'll promote
something right
so this reminds me do you guys remember
beyonce at one it like she performed at
uber's christmas party one year and they
gave her some equity she took it in
equity instead of cash and then when
uber went public obviously whatever uh
and
there's a there's a lyric where she says
pay me and equity um damn
damn but but do you think that
like kim
thought the same thing and was like oh
maybe if i take some in this
cryptocurrency in the future and they
sold her on this vision see i think that
ethereum max would have made it very
public if that was the case that's true
i think they would have said she got
paid in theory max all because that's
the biggest promotional thing you could
get is someone actually being paid in
your token when they're promoting it
right so i think they would have made it
clear and i don't think she would have
ever done it well to be fair i didn't
think she should have done in the first
place so uh but i don't think she would
have done it if she got paid in that
because it wouldn't have been cash and
she would have she i don't even think
she probably knows what ethereum max is
doesn't know you know all that stuff so
uh i think it it's confusing why she did
this but at the same time a lot of her
brand is based on promoting things and
and getting paid for social media and
stuff and she has a massive audience so
she's built it up uh and she monetized
it but at the end of the day you have to
be careful right because you don't want
to alienate fans you don't want people
to lose money who like you
and i hate to say but some people are
dumb you know what i mean they just go
and they follow things that celebrities
say right and and it's true for various
things and some celebrities are super
authentic with it and they try products
and they pitch things that they like and
they're super honest about it and all
that kind of stuff but some celebrities
aren't and i'm not saying kim is that
way i don't know her but at the end of
the day uh you have to be careful you
have to do your own research you have to
check into these things and you have to
know that just because a celebrity is
posing about it you should not go buy it
yourself most of the time if not all of
the time they are financially
incentivized to be telling you to go do
this so she put ad there but i don't
think that uh i i think people would be
shocked at the percentage of people that
follow her the 235 million followers at
the percentage of people that saw the
post and didn't even
put two and two together that she was
getting paid or just blindly followed
the advice and uh that's one of the
things that's always surprised me with
kind of these celebrity endorsements is
how many people are willingly going to
go and follow their advice without doing
any of their own research 100
but to be honest at the end of the day
it's just an instagram story like she
she got paid a ton of money to post an
instagram story about ethereum max she
probably she probably took it down
before 24 hours she doesn't really care
she was like thank you for the money and
uh she wanted about her day like she
probably got paid 500k for this would
you do it yes 100 percent for how much
yeah dario max you hit me up
very clear we'll talk about the ads and
the whole nine financial advice they're
not gonna let you post it if you put in
the comment don't buy this i'm not gonna
say don't buy this i'm gonna say do your
own research all right now y'all know if
john's posting about anything on social
media i'll still whatever
you mean
just just nix it he had he had the
profile sign up link in his twitter bio
for a long time
got recently replaced with sofi.com
go there sign up for a sofa account you
buy ten dollars worth of bitcoin you get
about ten dollars worth of bitcoin for
free i think it's what uh 20 around 20
000 sats right now so uh go to sofi.com
and i want to make something clear here
someone javi in the comments is saying
so you're saying not to listen to pomp
pushing bitcoin that's not what i'm
saying he owns a [ __ ] ton of bitcoin
himself his incentives are in line his
incentives are a line for the price he
talks about all the time he does a bunch
of research on it he is constantly
educating people on it so when someone
owns it themselves and they're saying
hey this is where my money is that's
when you should trust their opinion
because you know that they're doing the
research they're doing the work they
have skin in the game and they are
incentivized for it to go up as well kim
kardashian is the exact opposite in this
scenario where she probably has not done
any homework on this situation she does
probably not own any of it herself and
she's being financially promoted or
financially incentivized to promote it
not to own it trust me kim kardashian
probably did not live for two months
without a couch so she could buy a
theory
i did i did that's the only story you
need to hear that is the only story you
need to hear holly delivered on a couch
so they could keep stacking sounds
what's up guys bang bang thanks so much
for watching the best business show
today if we're gonna be the best
business show we obviously need the best
partner that's why the exclusive sponsor
the best business show is sofi they're
an all-in-one platform that allows you
to invest in all kinds of different
assets including stocks etfs crypto ipos
and they even have an automated
investing function if that's your thing
so before we start getting after it
again make sure that you go download
sofi you get an invest account and when
you make your first crypto trade
regardless of what you buy they'll give
you 10 in bitcoin for free it's that
simple head on over to sofi.com to get
started today thanks so much for
watching and i hope you come back and
watch more the best business show
tomorrow
[Music]